BUT FIRST, SAVING LIEUTENANT
COLONEL SCHALLER.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> OUR SON CALLED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT'S NO COINCIDENCE, IN MY
OPINION, THAT THEY PUT A GAG
ORDER ON HIM, AND THEY PUT HIM
IN PRISON THE DAY BEFORE THEY
HAD TO APPEAR IN FRONT OF
SENATORS AND TOMORROW IN FRONT
OF CONGRESSMAN.
I THINK -- I THINK THAT IS
FAIRLY AN ACT OF COWARDICE --
COWARDICE.
>> Laura: PARENTS ON THE ANGLE
LAST NIGHT, THE PARENTS OF
LIEUTENANT STUART SCHALLER
RATTLED THE CONSCIOUS -- THEY
RUN THE GAMUT OF FURY AND
DISBELIEF.
>> CAN'T TALK TO HIM, THEY DON'T
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE PHONE CALLS.
>> WE TALKED TO HIM FOR
2 MINUTES ON MONDAY MORNING WHEN
HE ASKED US TO CONTACT HIS
ATTORNEY, HE GOT ONE PHONE CALL.
>> WE HAVE HAD NO COMMUNICATION
WITH HIM.
HE NEEDS OUR HELP.
HIS FAMILY NEEDS OUR HELP AND WE
ARE ASKING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO WRITE THEIR CONGRESSMAN TO
SAY THAT IT'S NOT ALL RIGHT WITH
THEM, THEN WE NEED YOU TO SAY WE
WANT THEM TO RESIGN.
IF >> Laura: HOW CAN IT BE
THAT A HIGHLY RESPECTED 17 YEAR
MARINE WITH MULTIPLE TOURS OF
DUTY UNDER HIS BELT IS SITTING
IN THE BRIG TONIGHT FOR SAYING E
OBVIOUS LAST MONTH ABOUT OUR
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN?
>> PEOPLE ARE UPSET BECAUSE
THEIR SENIOR LEADERS LET THEM
DOWN AND NONE OF THEM ARE
RAISING THEIR HANDS AND
ACCEPTING ACCOUNTABILITY OR
SAYING WE MESSED THIS UP.
I'M NOT SAYING WE GOT TO BE IN
AFGHANISTAN FOREVER, BUT I AM
SAYING DID ANY OF YOU THROW YOUR
RANK ON THE TABLE AND SAY HEY,
IT'S A BAD IDEA TO EVACUATE
BAGRAM AIRFIELD, THE STRATEGIC
AIR BASE, BEFORE WE EVACUATE
EVERYONE?
>> Laura: BY MAKING THIS
COMMONS PUBLICLY AND CONTINUING
TO POST COMETS ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
SOME MILITARY LAW EXPERTS ARE
SAYING TO LIEUTENANT COLONEL
LIKELY, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
BROKE THE CHAIN OF COMMAND.
IF WELL, ON SATURDAY, SCHALLER
POSTED ON HIS FACEBOOK THAT HIS
SUPERIOR HAD ORDERED HIM TO STOP
POSTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE END OF THE POST WITH "I'M
READY FOR JAIL."
AND HE WAS TOSSED INTO THE BRIG.
IF ANYONE IS TRULY GUILTY OF
BREAKING THE CHAIN OF COMMAND OR
DISPARAGING THE MILITARY, IT'S
GENERAL MARK MILLEY.
BEFORE AND AFTER THE ELECTION,
HE HOPSCOTCHED OVER THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO COORDINATE
WITH HIS CHINESE COUNTERPART.
AND WHEN NANCY SAID DONALD TRUMP
WAS CRAZY, MILLEY SAID HE
AGREED.
BUT MILLEY REMAINS TYPICALLY
DISMISSIVE AND DEFIANCE.
>> AT NO TIME WAS I ATTEMPTING
TO CHANGE OR INFLUENCE THE
PROCESS, USURP AUTHORITY, OR
INSERT MYSELF IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
BUT I AM EXPECTED -- I AM
REQUIRED TO GIVE MY ADVICE AND
ENSURE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
FULLY INFORMED ON MILITARY
MATTERS.
>> Laura: NOW, WHO DESERVES TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE HERE?
A MARINE CORPS OFFICER WITH A
STELLAR CAREER, YET STILL RISKED
HIS PENSION AND BENEFITS TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT INCOMPETENT
MILITARY LEADERSHIP?
OR MILLEY, THE INCOMPETENT
LEADER WHOSE OWN FAILURE TO
SPEAK OUT LEFT 13 AMERICANS
DEAD?
THEY SQUAWK ABOUT AN
INSURRECTION, A THREE HOUR
INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6TH, BUT
WHAT YOU CALL A GENERAL AND
OTHER OFFICIALS TRYING TO USURP
THE ROLE OF OUR COMMANDER IN
CHIEF BECAUSE THEY HATED THE
ACTUAL COMMANDER IN CHIEF?
IT SEEMED LIKE HOUSE G.O.P.
MEMBERS WERE WATCHING LAST
NIGHT, BECAUSE TODAY, THEY
CONFRONTED MILLEY, AND DEFENSE
SECRETARY AUSTIN AND COMMANDER
McKENZIE ON THE BLATANT DOUBLE
STANDARD.
>> ONE PEOPLE IN THE MILITARY
LIKE LIEUTENANT COLONEL STUART
SCHELLER EXTEND UP AND DEMAND
ACCOUNT ABILITY, WHEN THEY SAY
YOU ALL SCREWED UP, HE ENDS UP
IN THE BREAK AND YOU ALL END UP
IN FRONT OF US.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT AND
DESERVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE
EVEN HAVE SERVICE MEMBER'S LIKE
LIEUTENANT COLONEL STUART
SCHELLER BEING THROWN IN THE
BRIG FOR SUGGESTING THAT.
THE PUBLIC SPACE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS CONTINUES TO ERODE
PRECISELY BECAUSE EVERYONE IN
THE D.C. BUBBLE APPEARS TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF IMMUNITY FROM THE
BASIC STANDARDS THE REST OF
AMERICA IS EXPECTED TO LIVE BY.
>> Laura: FOR NOT A TAKING
ACCOUNT ABILITY, WE KNOW THAT,
BUT WE ALSO ARE NEVER GOING TO
THE HOW MANY HOURS MILLEY SPENT
GABBING TO THE MEDIA.
>> YOUR TALKED ABOUT WATERED OR
ROBERT COSTA FOR THEIR BOOK?
>> WOODWARD, YES, CAUSTIC, NO.
>> DID YOU TALK TO CAROL JANIK
AND PHILIP BRECHER FOR THEIR
BOOK?
>> YES.
>> DID YOU TALK TO MICHAEL
BENDER FOR HIS BOOK?
>> YES.
>> AND WHERE YOU ACCURATELY
REPRESENTED IN THESE BOOKS?
>> I HAVEN'T READ ANY OF THE
BOOKS, SO I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: TOO BUSY READING
[INDISCERNIBLE] APPARENTLY.
WHO BELIEVES HE DIDN'T READ ANY
OF THE BOOKS, EVEN THE PAGES
WHERE HE WAS MENTIONED?
HE GAVE THE INTERVIEWS BECAUSE
HE WANTED TO FURNISH HIS OWN
REPUTATION AND PROTECT HIS
LEGACY FOR POSTERITY.
IN THESE HEARINGS, MILLEY,
AUSTIN, McKENZIE, THEY ALL
LOOK LIKE FOOTBALL COACHES ON A
FIVE-GAME LOSING STREAK.
THOSE GENERALS AREN'T LEADING
ANYONE TO VICTORY.
>> AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE QUESTIONS ON
MANY THINGS.
SUCH IS WHY WE TURNED OVER
BAGRAM AIRFIELD.
>> IN MY VIEW, THERE IS NO --
WAS NO RISK-FREE STATUS QUO
OPTION.
>> I DID NOT SEE ANY TACTICAL
UTILITY TO BAGRAM.
>> Laura: IMAGINE WHAT CHINA
THINKS OF THE GREAT AMERICAN WAR
MACHINE LED BY THESE MEN.
IF NOT BEING ABLE TO SECURE AN
AIR BASE LONG ENOUGH TO DO AN
ORDERLY EVACUATION?
FORCING OUR TROOPS TO DO AND
POSSIBLE PERIMETER SECURITY
DOING I.D. CHECKS WITH CROWDS
CRASHING TOWARD THEM BACK WHILE,
MILLEY DID ADMIT THE OBVIOUS,
THAT THE WITHDRAWAL WAS A
STRATEGIC FAILURE.
YOU THINK?
BUT HE STILL DOESN'T BELIEVE
ANYONE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT.
AND THE PENTAGON HAS ADMITTED
THEY MISTAKENLY KILLED TEN
CIVILIANS, INCLUDING SEVEN KIDS
IN THAT DRONE ATTACK.
SAME ANSWER THERE, NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THEY MIGHT AS WELL JUST HAVE
SAID "ARVADA," BUT OF COURSE NO
ONE RESIGNED, NO ONE WAS FIRED.
SIMPLY STUNNING.
BY CONTRAST, SCHELLER AND HIS
PARENTS EXCEPT THAT HE BROKE THE
RULES, EVEN IF HIS REASONS WERE
NOBLE.
>> WHILE STUART BROKE CHAIN OF
COMMAND, I CONTEND GENERAL WILL
McKENZIE, GENERAL MILLEY,
SECRETARY AUSTIN, THEY HAVE
BROKEN THE CHAIN OF TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND FOR THAT, THEY SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED.
>> THEY SHOULD DROP THEIR RANK.
>> THEY SHOULD DROP THEIR RANK
AND THEY SHOULD RESIGN FOR THAT.
>> Laura: THE ANGLE WAS THE
FIRST TO CALL FOR THOSE
RESIGNATIONS MORE THAN A MONTH
AGO, BUT TODAY, MILLEY MADE
CLEAR IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> GENERAL MILLEY, WILL YOU KNOW
RESIGN?
>> I SERVE AT THE PLEASURE OF
THE PRESIDENT, MR. JACKSON.
>> Laura: MR. JACKSON.
NOW, FOR THE ALLEGED CRIME OF
DEMANDING ACCOUNT ABILITY,
LIEUTENANT COLONEL SCHELLER WAS
STRIPPED OF HIS COMMAND AND
THROWN IN THE BRIG.
OF HIS PRETRIAL HEARING IS SET
FOR TOMORROW, ALTHOUGH HE HASN'T
YET BEEN FORMALLY CHARGED, HE
COULD FACE CHARGES OF ARTICLE
88, CONTEMPT TOWARD OFFICIALS,
ARTICLE 90, WILLFULLY DISOBEYING
A SUPERIOR COMMISSIONED OFFICER,
ARTICLE 92, FAILURE TO OBEY AN
ORDER, AND ARTICLE 133, CONDUCT
UNBECOMING AN OFFICER AND A
GENTLEMAN.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS, BUT
ALL OF THIS SMACKS OF POLITICAL
PAYBACK, DOESN'T IT?
AN OFFICIAL ATTEMPT TO SILENCE
AND INTIMIDATE DISSIDENTS WITHIN
THE RANKS.
IF YOU REMEMBER YOUR RUSSIAN
HISTORY, IF YOU STUDIED RUSSIAN
HISTORY, YOU WILL RECALL WHAT
THE SOVIETS DID TO THEIR
PRISONERS OF CONSCIENCE.
THE GOAL WAS TO STOP ALL DISSENT
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
BUT WE THE PEOPLE, WE HAVE A
SAY, WE CAN SPEAK OUT.
THEY CAN'T INTIMIDATE OR SILENCE
ALL OF US.
THEY WILL TRY, BUT THEY CAN'T.
WE NEED TO STAND UP FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO SPEAK
THE HARD TRUTHS PUBLICLY.
AMERICA HAS NOT BEEN BETRAYED BY
LIEUTENANT COLONEL SCHELLER.
IF AMERICA WAS BETRAYED BY O